so would anyone like to suggest to me
how can we make it so there is an oiler
path would you like to remove a bridge
out of bridge what do you want to do
yeah brendan
okay which bridge would you like me to
remove
any bridge do you guys think i can take
away any bridge it'll work
okay all right tell me which bridge i
should remove like i've got labels here
so
all of the bridges you can name them
right so i know there's a couple that
are sort of um redundant but which one
would you like me to take
out top left
top left so this one
this one over here
yeah
okay i mean brenda didn't say any of
them okay so
how do we know it works how do we know
it works i need another color
okay how should we do it would you like
to describe the path to it yeah
it's got a name
okay good start here good oh okay so
i'll go there's two yep go down back to
d okay there's three yeah then go to b
yep there's four
then go to
c
there there are five yep you go back to
a
six you go to b seven done
not so hard very good okay fantastic all
right i have a question for you right
can you start anywhere or does it matter
where you start does it matter where you
begin
does it matter can you start anywhere
you reckon we can start anywhere no
no
who thinks we can start anywhere
a few of you okay hands down so now
hands up who thinks you you can't start
anywhere there are places you can start
okay all right somebody still got their
hands up give me a place that i can't
start any suggestions
a
do you reckon we can't start at a we
just started
no we started a d
should we redraw it let's redraw it and
i've got
can i start today a
b
c
d and we took out that bridge so it's
like this
two there
okay so can we start at eight should we
try it
let's just try it let's see what happens
okay so i'm gonna start here where would
you like me to go first
give me give me somewhere okay see all
right so i've started here
oh i'm in trouble aren't i no matter
which way you go now you're stuck if i
come back to a you can't get to b or if
you go across to b you can't get back to
eight so i'm in trouble
okay now hot on a second
some people were convinced i should be
able to start anywhere that's not a bad
intuition to have but why is it wrong
why is it that in the first place when
annie had to go we started here and it
worked
what is it about vertex a that makes it
not work
you have to think about it have a think
about it in fact what i want you to do
is try to make a hypothesis now i want
you to write it down if you think you
have an idea i want you to say starting
with verdict a
will not work cannot work
because see if you fill it out